ahora hagamos un ejemplo un poco más
difícil del movimiento de proyectiles en
dos dimensiones en esta situación voy a
tener una plataforma
desde donde voy a lanzar mi proyectil de
hecho lo voy a dibujar un poco más abajo
para que tener
una mejor idea y ahí mi proyectil va a
aterrizar en otra plataforma que va a
estar un poco más abajo de la original
entonces voy a disparar mi proyectil
desde aquí más o menos
a esta altura de la plataforma y con un
ángulo
de 53 grados
53 grados
desde aquí va a ser voy a lanzar mi
proyectil y este proyectil va a salir
con una velocidad
va a salir disparado con una velocidad
de 90 metros sobre segundo
y para darnos una idea de la altura de
la que es lanzada y para lo que es
lanzado nuestro proyectil desde la boca
del cañón
hasta
suelo
esta altura es de 25 metros
y bueno de esto lo lanzamos y va a caer
a la altura 0 al nivel del suelo va a
caer encima de la plataforma y esta otra
plataforma tiene una altura
de 9 metros
en el vídeo anterior vimos que asumimos
que tenemos un proyectil que ha lanzado
desde el suelo a una altitud cero y
llegaba o caía de nuevo a una latitud
cero y ahora no va a ser no va a caer a
la misma altitud este proyectil cómo
vamos a resolver este problema lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
descomponer este vez este vector
velocidad en sus elementos verticales y
horizontales
vamos a usar la componente horizontal
para encontrar cuánto perón su
componente vertical primero para
encontrar cuánto tiempo estuvo en el
aire este proyectil y después junto con
la componente horizontal vamos a
calcular qué tan lejos llegó asumiendo
por supuesto que la resistencia al aire
es cero entonces dibujamos de nuevo
nuestro
el vector velocidad y aquí es su
magnitud es de 90 metros sobre segundo
está en un ángulo de 53 grados y lo que
queremos conocer ahora es su componente
tanto su componente horizontal como su
componente
vertical
y primero vamos a trabajar con la
componente vertical conocemos el ángulo
conocemos la hipotenusa de este
triángulo rectángulo
y bueno sabemos que para calcular este
lado necesitamos usar la fórmula
trigonométricas que me involucra un
cateto opuesto entre un cateto alias erc
que está de la función trigonométricas
en o como hemos visto en los vídeos
anteriores bueno tenemos que conocemos
el seno conocemos el ángulo 53 grados y
éste se no va a ser igual a la magnitud
de este vectores
llamado ve y dice y que es la componente
vertical de mi compone de mi vector
velocidad va a ser igual a
esta magnitud en g
dividida en 3
en la magnitud de la hipotenusa o en
este caso de mi ángulo que es de 90
metros sobre segundo voy a dejar de usar
unidades aquí para que me alcance el
espacio y les puedo mostrar cómo se
realiza esta operación entonces tenemos
que
esto si lo que me interesa saber es esta
parte voy a multiplicar ambos lados de
la ecuación por 90 y me va a quedar que
esta componente
vertical la magnitud es igual a 90
por el seno
de 53 grados
cuando resuelva esto entonces tendré el
valor de esta magnitud lo mismo voy a
hacer para mi componente horizontal en
este caso mi componente horizontal
es la que se encuentra adyacente al
ángulo entonces ahora en lugar de usar
el seno voy a usar la función
trigonométricas coseno de igual manera
aquí tengo que el coseno de 53 grados es
igual a
mm magnitud de la componente horizontal
entre la hipotenusa cuyo valor es de 90
grados pero 90
por lo que
este componente
su magnitud va a ser igual a
90 por el coseno 90 por el coseno
de 53 grados y estos son los valores con
los que está trabajando
bueno usaremos la componente vertical
para calcular cuánto tiempo está en el
aire en este caso tenemos que hay
diferentes niveles y no podemos usar
nuestro razonamiento básico de la vez
anterior sobre que la velocidad de esa
vida será la misma que la velocidad de
caída o de entrada o de llegada pues no
tenemos la misma elevación
lo que podemos hacer es usar la fórmula
que deducimos en el vídeo anterior esta
fórmula es la del desplazamiento es
igual a mi velocidad inicial
multiplicada por el cambio en el tiempo
más la
aceleración vamos a ponerle un color
diferente la aceleración
la aceleración de la gravedad
multiplicada por la componente o el
cambio del tiempo al cuadrado
este que se note que es una en 19 es una
esto dividido entre 2
cómo puedo usar esto para calcular el
tiempo en el aire bueno si comenzamos
con un buque hubo un desplazamiento
vertical de 25 metros y llegamos a un
desplazamiento vertical de 9 metros y
acá queda el proyectil este va a caer en
16 metros 16 metros viene siendo la
diferencia entre estos
25 metros menos los 9 metros de la
plataforma estos son 16 metros esta va a
ser la altitud a la que va a caer
la cola que va a caer mi proyectil
entonces este es el desplazamiento que
tiene mi proyectil está el bid anterior
vimos que este desplazamiento era cero
pero aquí si hay una diferencia en el
desplazamiento entonces existen
desplazamientos son de 16 metros aquí es
importante recordar que estamos tratando
con vectores y el desplazamiento
vertical de este proyectil va a recorrer
una distancia hacia abajo al momento de
caer
recuerden que nuestra convención es que
ponemos si la dirección de mi vector que
va hacia abajo lo voy a expresar con
cantidades negativas y si va hacia
arriba va a ser con cantidad positiva de
igual manera si tengo un vector que va
hacia la derecha va a ser lo voy a
representar con una cantidad positiva y
si va hacia la izquierda va a estar
representado con una cantidad negativa
así que este 16 en realidad es un menos
16 porque va hacia abajo mi
desplazamiento en la fórmula es menos 16
y esto va a ser igual a este componente
de velocidad
vamos a estar usando los elementos de la
componente vertical es mi desplazamiento
vertical por lo que voy a usar este
elemento para sustituir en esta en esta
fórmula entonces
mi velocidad inicial viene siendo
90 por el seno de 53
grados
y esto va a estar x
voy a poner los colores aquí
esto va estar multiplicado por mi
desplazamiento en el tiempo del tate
y a esto lo voy a sumar
la aceleración de la gravedad se que la
aceleración es hacia abajo y vale
-
9.8 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
pero como les digo aquí nos vamos a usar
las unidades esto va estar multiplicado
por el cambio en el tiempo al cuadrado y
va a estar dividido entre 2
simplificando un poco más esta operación
vamos a tener menos 9.8 entre 2 y esto
bueno este menos en realidad nos cambia
esta suma que en realidad va a ser una
resta ya que esta cantidad es negativa y
nos queda entonces que este
desplazamiento
menos 16 es igual a 90
senos de 53
x el cambio en el tiempo
- que iba a volver a poner un más pero
no es un menos
entonces menos 9.8 entre 2
el resultado es
4.9 multiplicado por la distancia hola
perdón a diferencia del tiempo al
cuadrado y esta es nuestra fórmula de
desplazamiento como lo vamos a resolver
pues aquí no podemos factorizar del tate
como lo hicimos en la vez anterior pero
ustedes podrán reconocer que esta es una
ecuación cuadrática y para resolverlas
vamos a poner todos los elementos de un
mismo lado de la ecuación así que voy a
reescribir nuevamente
ahora es 90 seno de 53 grados
bueno y de hecho tengo que empezar
escribiendo las convenciones escribir
primero el término que tiene más bueno
el l el elemento que está elevado al
cuadrado
entonces
escribo menos 4.9
4.9 del tate
al cuadrado
más
90 seno de 53
grados del tate
+ 16 veces que es nuestro desplazamiento
+ 16 y todo esto va a ser igual a 0 y
así tengo la estructura de una esta
ecuación cuadrática y esto lo puedo
solucionar en otros vídeos de álgebra se
han analizado cómo se resuelven este
tipo de ecuaciones les recomiendo que si
no están familiarizados con éstos vayan
a khan academy punto o hereje para
realizar estos vídeos de álgebra sin
embargo vamos a poner aquí cuál es la
forma para resolver una ecuación
cuadrática la fórmula si tenemos una
ecuación cuadrática con esta estructura
x cuadrada + b por x + c igual a cero
vamos a poder obtener dos raíces o dos
elementos que me resuelven esta ecuación
entonces la fórmula es menos b más menos
raíz cuadrada debe cuadrada - 4 a c
raíz cuadrada de todo esto
entre 2
y esto me va a dar las soluciones o los
valores que debe tomar x para que se
resuelva esta ecuación así que
sustituyendo estos en esta fórmula
voy a tener entonces
es este va a ser
bueno no exactamente este este
es
este elemento
es ven
y este elemento
ese entonces voy a sustituir cada uno de
estos en la fórmula entonces tengo que
delta que va a ser igual a
menos
90 seno de 53
más menos
más menos la raíz cuadrada de
de cuadrada de nuevo bueno ya cuadradas
y es 90 seno de 53 grados al cuadrado
menos
cuatro veces
y viene siendo menos 4.9
-
4.9
x sé que es 16
va a ser la raíz cuadrada de todo esto
y va a estar dividido
entre 2
y
2a que viene siendo
2 x menos
4.9 es bastante
bastantes operaciones pero bueno sin
embargo con esto podemos resolver
nos interesa solo la raíz positiva aquí
nos va a tener dos valores pero cuando
estamos hablando de tiempo como que no
tiene sentido
encontrar un tiempo negativo como que
suena que regresaríamos al pasado y
bueno realmente nuestra realidad esto no
va a aplicar así que voy a buscar que
este valor en total sea un valor
positivo
sea este un tiempo positivo para que sea
congruente con nuestra realidad entonces
para que esto sea así
vamos a analizar un poquito los números
aquí tengo un valor negativo
y aquí en esta multiplicación en el
denominador me va a quedar una es una
cantidad negativa para que todo esto sea
positivo tengo que asegurar que lo que
esté arriba sea también negativo para
que negativo entre negativo se haga
positivo y me salga un tiempo positivo
para garantizar que esta cantidad de va
a ser negativa voy a hacer el cálculo
usando esta el menos en lugar del más
para no alargar el tiempo del vídeo que
ya realmente me ha alargado un poquito
les invito a que ustedes hagan con su
calculadora estas operaciones y estas
cantidades yo
he hecho las operaciones aparte y ya
tengo los valores que van a quedar en el
numerador y en el denominador pero les
pido o les invito para que ustedes
también hagan esas operaciones en su
calculadora y verifiquen los valores en
el numerador me va a quedar 1 menos 145
punto 90 y en el denominador me va a
quedar un menos 9.8
que si yo hago esta operación esta
división me va a quedar un
14.89 y como estamos hablando de tiempo
van a ser 14.89 segundos esta es la
cantidad de tiempo que el proyectil paso
en el aire y si queremos saber qué tan
lejos llegó pues vamos a multiplicar
este tiempo por la componente horizontal
de la velocidad este que calculamos en
este principio vamos a usar ahora esta
parte en combinación con el tiempo
entonces mi desplazamiento en x
en la componente horizontal es igual a
la velocidad que en este caso la
calculamos como 90 por coseno de 53
por
coseno de 53
multiplicada por el cambio en el tiempo
y el cambio en el tiempo lo calculamos
multiplicada por
14.89 nuevamente los invito a que hagan
la operación los cálculos y les debe de
salir un resultado de
806 metros como desplazamiento
desde este punto desde que se lanzó el
cañón hasta que aterrizó hasta que cayó
se desplazó 800 6 metros
y hasta aquí llegamos con este vídeo